all right final event we're going to
cover from the weekend is the day after
on Sunday Trump did another rally in
Florida Miami Florida for Marco Rubio he
did not Rally for Ron DeSantis Rhonda
Santos was not invited although Trump
did say re-elect Ron DeSantis after
people were mad that he called them
Rhonda sanctimonious the energy was
particularly scary at this one now often
at the rallies Trump is sweating and
dripping but this one actually had
pouring rain we'll get to that in a
moment
scary energy and Trump's starting with
Nancy Pelosi whose husband recently
needed skull surgery because of a
lunatic right-wing attacker who bashed
his head in with a skull listen to what
Trump says this is this was just a cabal
this was just a group of people where
crazy Nancy Pelosi by the way how's she
doing lately how's she doing
we're crazy Nancy Pelosi has the votes
how is she doing she's probably
extremely traumatized from what one of
Trump's followers did to her husband and
then even more disgusting they start
chanting lock her up about Nancy Pelosi
she hasn't been charged or she's not
even being investigated for a crime
up and down the ballot Republican and
we're going to end crazy Nancy Pelosi's
political career once and for all once
and for all
under Biden Pelosi Schumer in the
radical democrat congress Florida
workers and families are under siege
Locker up right I mean they're for due
process and Law and Order and lock up a
woman who's not even being investigated
for any crime truly truly dangerous
Trump then did his uh racist dog whistle
about Mitch McConnell's wife Elaine Chow
in SC you got to get Mitch McConnell to
be a lot tougher Mitch McConnell you can
have Mitch McConnell and his wife Coco
Coco Chow you can have them both Coco
Chow is uh Trump's latest uh sort of uh
xenophobic dog whistle about Elaine ciao
horrifying stuff and the crowd just I
mean totally they're completely unfazed
by it Trump did as I mentioned get
enough backlash about saying Ron de
sanctimonious about Ron DeSantis on
Saturday night
so by yesterday afternoon he did the
absolute bare minimum and was like yeah
yeah re-elect Rhonda Santa's governor
and you're going to re-elect Rhonda
Sanchez as your governor of your state
[Applause]
he did it he held his nose but he did it
and then we'll talk about
um uh this in a different context but
Donald Trump also talking about how much
suffering there has been
for his own children imagine that they
are the real victims here
oh I just happened to catch about half
of his speech I got in and I said who's
ripping it up there
and it was a person named Don Trump Jr
[Applause]
and he's great and he's great you know I
have to tell this one sir because he
said he goes I could tell he's probably
heard me tell it a couple of times that
much but to show you how evil these
people are
so don went to Great school he went to
the Wharton School of Finance all this
stuff good student he was great he was
no problem whatsoever he's just a good
young guy
and I decided to go into politics I said
you know life is too good everything's
perfect let's screw up your life a
little bit okay
and so I take my family along with me
and uh that you know they've really
suffered when you think of it but they
they don't have any second questions
they've really suffered his family
really made the sacrifice Donald Trump
does tease that he might announce his
candidacy for president tonight which
we'll talk about later I will probably
have to do it again but stay tuned
foreign
[Applause]
and then he drops this about Ohio
tonight
pretty good thank you
[Applause]
stay tuned to tomorrow night in the
great state of Ohio yeah so there's a
report that Trump's going to announce
next Monday we'll talk about that in a
moment and then lastly it quite
literally started pouring during the
rally and Donald Trump made a big deal
out of the fact that he was heroically
staying out there to speak to his
followers
and just two years ago we had a red
China Russia and North Korea in China
[Applause]
and they weren't going to do a thing
against us
[Music]
[Applause]
anyway it was pouring and Trump was
soaked and they all made a big deal out
of how heroic it was to stay out there
these rallies are extremely dangerous
the people are weaponized today we will
have competing rallies Barack Obama and
Trump trumps in Ohio I forget where
Obama is we will have them live later
okay we're going to take a quick break
if you watch us on YouTube and you're
not yet subscribed make sure to
subscribe subscribe to the podcast and
we'll be back right after this
plastic is everywhere we look and not
enough is being done about it 100
billion plastic bags are used and thrown
away every year but you can help make a
change our sponsor hold on makes trash
and kitchen bags that are heavy duty
plant-based non-toxic and 100 home
compostable which means they break down
in weeks rather than decades they don't
fill up our landfills they don't pollute
our oceans they're zip seal kitchen bags
come in sandwich or gallon bag sizes to
fit your needs and the best part about
hold on bags is they work I use them at
home they're just as good as all of the
name brand bags you fill them up they
stretch and they don't break everybody
uses trash bags and freezer bags if you
care about the planet you can do
something by using hold on bags instead
and it's a really easy way to do your
part go shop plant-based bags to replace
single-use Plastics all over your home
you'll save 20 20 percent when you go to
holdon bags.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman the link is down below